[Música]
como están soy marcela y soy diseñador
estratégica
y para mí decir hasta aquí es un honor
porque primero que nada ni mis papás
entienden bien todavía qué es lo que yo
hago bien qué es lo que me han estado
apoyando tantos años y es algo que
esencialmente ha sido muy nuevo por
muchos años aquí en nuestros países pero
que tiene 10 15 20 años de verdad estar
influenciando europa y eeuu y lo que más
me llama la atención es que en la
industria financiera ahora sí se están
dando cuenta que agregamos mucho valor
que los diseñadores tenemos que ser
parte de sus equipos y ya no a un nivel
táctico a donde estamos detrás de una
computadora recibiendo las órdenes de
alguien de mercadeo haciendo un arte
bonito sino más bien ya asentándonos en
la mesa de los grandes poniendo nuestra
opinión y a pesar de hacer de esos
millenials de los que hablaban por ahí
muy jóvenes venir a de verdad tomar
decisiones importantes al lado de
ustedes porque tenemos esa influencia de
diseñar el futuro el futuro de la banca
y esa capacidad de diseño creo que la
tenemos todos y posiblemente todos aquí
somos creativos de alguna manera
solucionando problemas de nuestro día a
día pero lo que sucede es que no muy
comúnmente nos tomamos el tiempo de
salirnos de ese día a día y trabajar
colaborativamente de empezar a pensar en
temas estratégicos a nivel de diseño a
nivel de diseño centrado en un usuario
porque lo que sucede es que en una
estructura
en la institución financiera donde son
tan complejas y robustas estamos
segmentados en diferentes áreas de
trabajo y así lo están muchas
organizaciones y negocios sin embargo
vamos fragmentando a ese cliente en
pedacitos a un nivel donde la
experiencia de ese cliente ya no es una
experiencia verdaderamente fluida sino
que es una experiencia súper agotadora
en la que sentimos como esta partida en
pedacitos y que ya nosotros no somos el
centro sino que es realmente el
backstage de todo lo que debería estar
alineado para que yo vea una experiencia
mágica
y todo se ha ido complicando un poco
porque antes digamos que era muy fácil
diseñar un producto que fuera diferente
en el mercado nos diferencia vamos por
una o dos características y hoy en día
que estamos en la era de las
experiencias y de los servicios a donde
nacen todos estos disruptores a donde
nosotros los millennials estamos pegados
al teléfono pidiendo uber it's aplicando
a un apartamento en ir bien vi para mis
vacaciones utilizando a amazon prime
llegó un momento en donde estás estás
marcas que nos hace sentir magia están
diseñadas a tal punto que por ejemplo yo
que pido bits por lo menos dos veces a
la semana posiblemente aunque me paguen
una de esas dos veces siempre lo vuelva
a pedir yo digo que bruta que soy que
vuelvo a pedir u verista a pesar de que
me traen el pedido de saber que fulano
en otra parte de mi colonia y es que
pónganse a pensar 30 segundos después de
que yo reclamo me han devuelto mi dinero
entonces el final bueno me comí una
hamburguesa y no una pista pero estaba
rica y no me la cobraron
y el día siguiente a las once y media de
la mañana antes de que vaya a almorzar
me antón con algo que es mi producto
favorito ellos ya saben cuál es el
restaurante del que más pido y está para
sólo hacer un clic entonces como no me
enamoro de ellos como no prefiero yo
pedí de cvr eats que agarrar mi carro y
montarme a buscar algo que quiero comer
pero como hacen estas marcas para
generar estos diseños estos servicios
estas experiencias casi mágicas y yo le
vengo a hablar hoy de design thinking o
pensamiento de diseño que es una
metodología que todas estas marcas
tienen en común que todas estas marcas
han decidido integrar al adn del corazón
de su negocio y básicamente consta en
cuatro pasos bastante sencillos el
primero es empatizar es entender perdón
es entender el reto estratégico que
estamos queriendo
puedes imaginarnos esa visión nueva que
vamos a hacer luego es empatizar y salir
del quinto piso
a tratar de tener esa conexión emocional
con el cliente 30 es ya ideal de una
manera enfocada basándonos en esa
empatía que realizamos y en ese
entendimiento del problema estratégico
que tenemos y por último prototipar o
crear experimentos que nos permitan
aprender muy rápidamente qué es lo que
no estamos quizás entendiendo muy bien
del cliente regresar a la mesa de
trabajo cambiar algunas cosas y seguir
adelante y lo que se hace primero en la
parte de entender de entender el reto
como les decía era definir un reto
estratégico y sobre todo alinear a todas
las partes del negocio en este caso de
institución financiera
todos estos departamentos a pensar
juntos a traer aquí a una sesión de
trabajo o varias en la que ese reto
quede muy claro y que sea nivel en todos
esos conocimientos que pueden haber de
un área de otra área para que entendamos
muy bien de todas sus aristas ese
problema que queremos solucionar cómo lo
vamos a hacer y que puede traer a la
mesa cada una de las partes
pero en esta parte de entender puede
suceder algo muy interesante que es que
ya los bancos y muchos aquí lo están
haciendo ha tenido incluso la gran
oportunidad de trabajar con algunos de
ustedes en mapear estas experiencias del
cliente en utilizar post-its en llenar
las paredes de ese conocimiento que
tenemos del cliente de lo que le estamos
entregando hoy actualmente manejamos
cuáles son sus puntos de dolor cuáles
son sus momentos de alegría y esto lo
estamos haciendo muy bien sin embargo
hay algo que a veces no estamos viendo
que es todo lo que pasa en el backstage
que le llamamos cómo estamos alineando
nos nosotros a lo interno para que por
ejemplo un cliente que está tal vez
pidiendo una hipoteca un crédito
hipotecario que se está jugando la casa
de sus sueños tal vez apostando a una
casa que se imaginó siempre tener y
están otras dos parejas compitiendo y
tienen otro banco que tal vez más rápido
que el nuestro puede ser que ese cliente
se quede sin la casa de sus sueños
porque nosotros adentro de la casa no
nos organizamos para entregarle ese
sueño y esas son las cosas y las
conexiones emocionales
que si nosotros nos salimos a empatizar
nunca vamos a comprender de verdad lo
que puede sentir ese cliente y lo
interesante a la hora de empatizar es
que muchas veces queremos salir y
escuchar al cliente pero no con la
intención de entenderlo sino que más
bien de responderle de darle una
respuesta con nuestros sombreros
expertos en la banca que tenemos cinco
días quince años de trabajar en la banca
pero no estamos haciendo no nos estamos
deteniendo de verdad escuchar sus
sentimientos a tomarnos una hora de
nuestro tiempo
para invitarlos a estar con nosotros ya
escuchar qué es lo que dicen de verdad
de corazón y esta imagen que les muestro
acá es de una madre de familia en
jamaica con quien pude tener la
oportunidad de conversar por una hora y
me encantó porque viajó una hora para
empezar para ir a hablar con nosotros al
banco a pesar de que era algo que uno no
se imaginaría ser voy a ir a manejar una
hora al banco para contarle todos mis
problemas eso fue lo que yo me imaginé
cuando supe que iba a ser eso la
realidad fue que no ella llegó a
contarnos la historia de cuando su mamá
la llevó por primera vez al banco y le
abrió su cuenta y como ahí aprendió a
ahorrar en este banco que tiene 140 años
de existir y que a pesar de que están
bastante quedados en el tema digital
ella le encanta me encanta el banco y
así no solo ella muchos hicimos esa
conexión tan emocional que tenía la
marca la marca esteban con las emociones
que tenían él la conexión que tenían
sobre todo con la gente que les atendía
se los podían de nombre y apellido todas
esas lecciones que aprendimos en la
etapa de empatía fueron lo que después
nos pueden llevar por ejemplo a una
ideación focalizada enfocada no
a lo loco no a lo loco tirando ideas de
todo lo que se nos ocurra a los que
estamos aquí a los diferentes
departamentos pensando inclusive
lo que me conviene más a mí que se haga
de proyecto porque entonces yo llego a
mi meta más rápido no sino más bien
pensando en el dolor del cliente
enfocada mente y estratégicamente
entonces esa es la parte importante de
ideación sí es importante tomarme el
tiempo de ponernos creativos de crear
juegos dinámicas lo que sea para
trabajar juntos y desarrollar ideas pero
no es lo más importante como para decir
voy a empezar por la etapa de ideación
si nos saltamos la etapa de entender y
la etapa de empatizar muy probablemente
es la etapa de idear no nos va a salir
tan bien
por último la etapa de prototipar lo que
nos permite es generar experimentos de
poco con pocos recursos y con poco
tiempo que nos ayuden a seguir estando
cerca de esos clientes y llevarles como
por ejemplo un vídeo un storyboard una
maqueta de algo sencillo que muestre esa
visión exponencial de futurista que nos
estamos imaginando que le queremos
entregar al cliente y priorizar de todo
eso que de verdad podemos desarrollar
primero para agregarle mayor valor al
cliente en un quick win
y en resumen esta metodología es súper
flexible y si la hacemos bien y nos
enfocamos en hacerla con equipos
multidisciplinarios dedicados podemos
hacerlo en tan solo cuatro meses antes
de empezar a desarrollar y alguien que
lo está haciendo súper bien es bbva que
a pesar de que tiene la complejidad de
estar en 35 países y que tiene 70
millones de clientes está innovando a
punta de design thinking y este es el
sello de bbva y él es la persona que
está liderando este esfuerzo para llevar
ese mensaje de transformemos el banco a
través de esta metodología porque
realmente cree en ella y creo que eso es
algo importantísimo y que define si de
saint thinking va a funcionar o no
porque puede suceder que
algunas personas algunos negocios
algunas instituciones financieras digan
bueno pero es que eso ya lo probamos en
el sabor del mes y si puede ser que sea
cierto porque puede ser que no se haya
hecho y se haya tomado el tiempo para
tomar esas decisiones estratégicas de
pensar cuáles son las renuncias que se
tienen que hacer para que esté design
singing funcione se integre con todos
los departamentos y camine
y bbv no solamente el siguió quien lo
impulsa son todos los líderes que han
llegado ya a darse cuenta que antes
trabajaban en silos ahora ya no están
trabajando en silos están trabajando con
una visión muy clara en común para poder
llegar a ser inclusive el mejor en en la
banca móvil de todo el mundo este
galardón lo ganaron en 2017 y tienen
tres años consecutivos de estarlos
ganando en europa
y como lo están haciendo cómo están
ellos ejecutando el tema del desayuno
pues ellos le llaman el 3 69 el 3 69
básicamente lo que les permite es
y desplegar equipos de trabajo en tres
días
en seis semanas llegar a un prototipo
aterrizado un concepto y en nueve meses
estaré entregando valor al cliente y así
a pesar de que sean los mejores de los
mejores en temas de banca móvil a nivel
mundial ellos siguen mejorando a través
de design thinking ya no enfocados en un
tema estratégico de cómo ser el mejor
banco con el banca móvil sino pensando
en a qué empresa de tecnología puedo yo
vencer o si a asimilar me para seguir
siendo el mejor en el mercado para estar
siempre adelante y el próximo ejemplo
que les traigo es de un banco un poco
más nuevo sólo tiene seis años de
existir pero en estos seis años de
existir tienen pasaron de 12 clientes
a 7 millones de clientes o me parece que
15 millones de clientes fueron la
referencia que dieron en la charla
anterior y es impresionante como algo
tan sencillo como una tarjeta de crédito
en la cual no tienes que pasar por un
tema burocrático de papeles no tenés que
pagar ningún tipo de d
anualidades ni ningún otro tipo de
cobros se puede entregar algo que de
verdad sea de valor para ti y esto me
pasó a mí personalmente aquí siendo
extranjera viviendo en costa rica ya
tengo tres años de vivir aquí soy
salvadoreña para los que no sabían y es
impresionante que en el banco en el que
estoy no me permitieron tener de una
tarjeta de crédito a pesar que tengo
toda la posibilidad de tenerlo yo siendo
la mui millennial que nunca ha tenido
tarjetas de crédito ni aquí ni en la
china verdad decidí sabe que el banco no
me interesa tendrá su tarjeta de crédito
porque prefiero seguir pagando mi vida
con mi propio dinero que embarrarme a
meterme a hacer 100.000 papeles si son
cosas así que este tipo de bancos
completamente digitales si nos pueden
ofrecer que si se pueden dar el lujo de
decirle un cliente sabe que aquí está no
han días en horas
aquí está su tarjeta y a mí se me vienen
con eso yo o sea me cambió el banco ya
está lista según está mañana pero
entonces esos son el tipo de cosas que
nosotros los millennials verdad
que somos el enemigo del banco realmente
no lo somos solo nos tienen que entender
un poquitito más
qué es lo que tiene de valores
estratégicos know bank que en el en el
adn de ellos sus fundamentos de por sí
son el diseño y la experiencia
acompañado obviamente de la tecnología y
de los datos entonces si se imaginan la
combinación perfecta que puede ser esto
este tipo de valores que puedan tener y
vivir no solamente en ahí pegados en la
pared sino que que la gente lo siente lo
vive que los equipos de trabajo se
desarrollen de esta manera y el mensaje
final que quiero darles es que las
empresas que están centradas en diseño
son rentables esto no jugando no es pero
pongamos unos papelitos ahí en la pared
que sean de colores nos tomamos una foto
y ya le decimos ahí al jefe que ya
hicimos
lo pueden hacer así pero no lo solo
recomiendo si lo hacen bien las empresas
que están centradas en el usuario
destacan a un 211 por ciento de
rentabilidad sobre la 60 y five hundred
entonces los invito de verdad a montarse
al barco del diseño y aquí decidimos
juntos la banca del futuro muchas
gracias
[Música]